it's friday and that means it's time for
friday follies and for that we have a
special guest the legendary joe piscopo
host of the joe piscopo show on set with
me joe what an honor what a pleasure
thank you for being here now even
members of his own family are now
questioning the other joe's joe biden's
ability to lead or his own party rather
there seemed to be a lot of confusion
this week joe and not only from the
president watch
my husband and i were staying in
delaware so we could be near
the vice president-elect i mean
president-elect at the time i want to
thank the vice president vice president
harris and second general for allowing
us
to join them no it's joining us i'm just
stating a basic fundamental notion the
fastest way to restore woe roe
is to pass a national law codifying row
10 years old
and she was forced to have to travel out
of the state to indiana
to seek to terminate the presidency and
maybe save her life
terminate the presidency
and restoring woe to the land
your thoughts as you watch this well i
know you're a jerry lewis fan i am and
and sam and sandra
jerry's widow and from jerry lewis films
yeah very excited that we're together
because we're going to do the jerry
lewis movie you remember jerry i think
it was the errand boy every time he
couldn't pronounce the words
who's just a high you're you're a nice
man who's that high it's like but jerry
wasn't president no but every time i
watched by it's like
well
and jerry brought joy not wolves
i'm not so sure about and it's not just
these confused moments 54 of americans
joe in an abc washington post poll
thought biden lacked the mental
sharpness to serve as president here's
what people on the streets of new york
told me
joe biden
some members of his party don't want him
to run next time they say he's not
mentally or physically competent
how do you feel
[Music]
do you think he's up to the task
i think so
you know it's uh it's tough growing old
he's hanging in there but yeah he's
probably not going to make it for
another
session all right running i think it's a
different story we'll see there when we
get there okay why the hell would i take
a test
come on man he can do a little bit
better absolutely so you have confidence
in his leadership i have confidence in
none of our elected leaders we've seen
him physically stumble unfortunately
create some embarrassing times for him
you know we need leadership right now
right and i think i think the whole
world whatever side you're on would
agree with that yeah so i don't know
like i guess it really don't matter at
this point but i i wouldn't if i were
him i wouldn't
i know a lot of 80 year olds that are
very competent i don't think he's
competent but i know that where is
pushing us is not where i want to go
joe people forget trump is three years
younger than joey yeah but it's so it's
not a matter of age it's really about
the fitness at that age it's so true and
donald trump looks better now he's the
only president that didn't age you know
but you know what i'm older man you're a
young man
oh please though please i'm thinking to
myself we're all going to get there but
we're all not going to be president of
the united states hopefully this spouse
would stop you no i i well that's the
thing too did you see the marking look
as you look at the deal they have stage
markings like they're doing a play a
little tape yeah you see the tape look
at the bottom of your screen you see the
tape down there
where everybody has to stand you know
that's every white house event ice cream
i just want ice cream this poor guy
okay i've got to get to this before we
run out of time the biden administration
has recruited everyone from bts to
olivia rodrigo as you know to help
advance their agenda now in the midst of
a gas crisis while she blocks gas and
oil exploration biden's energy secretary
jennifer granholm is turning to a
hollywood heavyweight to recruit her
clean energy core
you might have seen me at one of my many
day jobs
billionaire superhero
world's greatest detective
alpaca wrangler but now i've got the
sweet new office over the department of
energy
coffee madam secretary thanks robert
early start today yeah pretty early well
that 62 billion dollars from congress
isn't going to spend itself robert
downey jr referencing the 62 billion
dollars congress appropriated for this
clean energy core joe
your reaction how about for the xl
pipeline how about working for the for
the pipeline how about being the the
supply chain how about doing that i love
robert downey jr how cool is that guy i
i was destroyed when an end game when he
died iron man died and now he's with
this gal this gal that said i'll wave a
magic wand for energy
robert we love you don't do that do it
this is truly avengers end game joe
iron man couldn't lift off the ground
with this group powering his backpack
don't do that don't do it joe piscopo
what an honor
lori lightfoot
speaking of ladies promised the summer
of joy in chicago but it's anything but
one southside pastor is enraged at how
leaders are threatening or treating
rather the bloodshed in his city he
joins us next
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else